the key difference between the crown
jewels and the Queen's Private
Collection is that the private
collection we know much less about these
are gifts that were given to the queen
over the Decades of her Reign but the
crown jewels belong to the Monarch they
are handed from Monarch to Monarch in
trust for the nation so technically they
belong to the Monarch but the Monarch
isn't allowed to run off with the crown
jewels they stay guarded at the Tower of
London in safe keeping for the nation
and when one Monarch dies the crown
jewels are immediately passed to their
Heir the queen has a very sizable and
very valuable Private Jewelry collection
and she has actually loaned in the past
quite a few pieces out to other female
members of the royal family for example
when Kate went to New Zealand the queen
loaned her a diamond Fern to wear
because that's the national symbol of
New Zealand when she went to Canada the
queen lent her the maple brooch which
had been gifted to the Queen by the
nation so these are quite emblematic
pieces of jewelry more often than not
they are diamonds they are worth a huge
amount of money and while we won't get
to see details of the Queen's private
will because it is exactly that private
I think over the coming months and years
we will see exactly whom she's
distributed her jewelry to because they
will be wearing it we've already seen
the queen pass over quite a few of her
pieces particularly to The Duchess of
Cambridge there is a hierarchy in all of
this the queen consort really gets first
choice of the Queen's jewelry and after
that it is the Princess of Wales of
course Kate The Duchess of Sussex I'm
sure will come in for some Jewelery at
some point but she is much further down
the picking order we saw Kate wearing a
pair of pearl earrings a present from
the queen for that um procession as they
went to the lying in state so jewelry is
used by the royal family as a very
subtle way of paying a message sending a
message whether that's wearing the
national emblem of a country when they
go to visit that country or in the case
of the Princess of Wales just paying
tribute to the Queen by wearing those
beautiful pearl earrings that the queen
had given to her Megan Duchess of Sussex
was seen wearing a pair of pearl
earrings that she'd been gifted from the
queen and she chose to wear them for
that service at the procession to the
lying of state so again the jewelry is
really important it might not
necessarily be worth a fortune but the
sentimental value of that you can't
really put a price on it there are some
very iconic pieces of jewelry and that
have been passed through the ages the
love is not Tiara for example which is
said to be worth 4 million based on the
intricate design of pearls and diamonds
is now been passed on to Princess of
Wales and the Princess of Wales before
Kate wore it but she used to complain it
was so heavy she didn't enjoy wearing it
at all in fact the queen had given it to
Lady Diana Spencer to wear on her
wedding day but it was so heavy for
Diana that she chose to wear the Spencer
Tiara instead Kate seems to manage
wearing it with gray great comfort and
that is Kate's go-to Tiara of choice so
more often than not if it's a state
reception or a banquet you'll see Kate
wearing that Lover's not Tiara which as
I say is worth 4 million but again when
you consider its history and its
Heritage and the Queens who have worn it
upon their heads in the past
it's in value you know it's hard to put
a value on it
[Music]